vous pouvez désormais sur votre
smartphone de Samsung dire sélectionner
un personnage comme on le faisait sur
iOS sauf que là vous ne pouviez pas le
faire et maintenant vous pouvez le faire
donc là pour venir sélectionner votre
petit personnage alors à la différence
sur iOS vous pouvez venir sortir de là
le coller dans une application l'envoyer
dans un message ici c'est pas possible
ici pour venir le copier vous allez
ensuite dans une note par exemple et
vous venez le coller dans une autre très
facilement vous laissez votre doigt
appuyer vous venez le coller vous allez
retrouver ici pour dire l'agrandir
mettre des légendes écrire griffonner
pourquoi pas avec votre S-Pen coucou
mais vous pouvez également venir
enregistrer directement
votre vous la retrouver ici directement
dans votre galerie c'est bien c'est
pratique mais ça ne va pas aussi loin
que ce que fait Apple avec iOS mais bon
voilà c'est un bon début ça continue à
voir ce que Samsung nous fera plus tard
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous connaissez
cette astuce est-ce qu'elle peut vous
intéresser marquer le moi dans les
commentaires